Good morning, John.
So, as you can tell by the headphones,
the different camera angle, the length
of the video, we're doing something
a little bit different today. I wanted to
take an opportunity to talk to somebody who
is a part of this community, watched her first
Vlogbrothers video in 2007, and also is just
a really amazing person who does a lot of amazing
work doing advocacy, and activism, and strategy,
and writing. Most recently, she was the campaign
manager for Julian Castro. She's now working
with Elizabeth Warren. I think we're really
lucky to have her as part of this community.
So I wanted to take a little bit of time to
talk to Maya Rupert. Obviously it's a hard time,
so Maya, I guess I'll just start out
by asking, how are you feeling right now?
[Maya:]
This is a hard time. And this has been a very hard time,
even as I feel like I have been someone,
I've worked in these spaces a lot,
and I feel like I have a pretty high capacity
for, "Things are going badly, but there's a
light at the end of the tunnel" and that kind
of thing. These last couple of weeks have
hit me really hard. And I know they're hitting
a lot of people really hard. And so, I'm hanging in,
I'm taking a lot of solace, in the fact
that I know a lot of people are feeling this
right now and are making community where they
can, and are being there for each other, which
is always the thing that I can take solace
in, in these moments, because that gives me
hope that there is somewhere we're trying
to go with this. But I mean, this is a tough
time and this one really does feel different.
[Hank:]
From the perspective inside of
presidential politics at this point,
which is a world of its own, I'm sure,
can you give me a little bit of a feeling for what
it looks like from that perspective?
[Maya:]
A lot of leaders right now are looking to,
"What can we put energy behind, and what can
people be doing?" And I think that is helpful.
I think that people want to feel right now,
there's something to do and ways that they
can act. One of the things I'm always struck
by when we talk about police violence, is
that people feel... There's the hopelessness
that comes with it that I think is understandable,
but then there's a piece of hopelessness that
I've never quite been able to square because
there's the sense of, "Well, what can we do?"
There's only so much that can be done.
But the thing is that a system that works like
this, this was policy that makes it possible
for police officers to act in dangerous ways,
and not be held accountable.
So there are policy solutions to it.
So I think,
sometimes there's a disconnect.
I feel like people aren't as conscious of
that as they should be. And so I'm really
heartened by all the work that people are
doing right now to point to policy suggestions that
are about what can happen, national use of
force standards requiring cops to deescalate
before any kind of fatal force is used. Some
of these things that will have huge, huge impacts
on these situations, moving forward.
So I think that we do have a moment from just
a political standpoint to, this is when we
need to be calling electives, letting people
know that this is a priority and making sure
that at every level of government, local,
state, federal, this is something that people
are are prioritizing and we're getting
folks in office that are going to take this
issue seriously.
[Hank:]
You and I are about the same age, so we're...
we've lived through some history at this point.
[Maya:] Right.
[Hank:] But I'm wondering how you feel
about the youths right now,
and if that is a source of any
encouragement for you right now.
[Maya:]
I'm always taken by young people, and how
people are activating in these moments of
crisis. I'm so excited to see how people are
looking at this and demanding more. And I
think it's always a tough thing generationally,
when we're doing move at work or in organizing,
I think that there's this, just by nature
of how these things work, as you get older,
there are more things that you have lived through,
you've seen things work so differently.
And so you're willing to put up with things
that younger people aren't. And I think,
one thing that I always try to
encourage people it's, as you become the older
people in the movement, try to have the humility
to recognize that the movement is changing.
And as you are the younger people in the movement,
have the grace to realize that the people
who have gone through it, they just had different
formative experiences. And so I think I'm
definitely at that point of the movement now,
where I'm asking for the grace and calling
on my humility. But what is, I think, really
cool about that cycle is that it means you
get to watch this new generation of people
who look at this and say,
"This far, no further,
and we are not compromising."
And so I'm really excited
that I'm getting
to see this generation take this issue on,
because it is one that needs that kind of
attention, that kind of demand, that kind
of unwillingness to compromise.
I'm seeing that a lot, I'm seeing that with the folks
that have taken to the streets. And it's weird,
because there's an urgency to it, and I really
have a lot of faith in this generation of
organizers to really make sure that as much
as this moment feels different,
that this actually can be
different this time.
[Hank:]
I think that it's important that we have fuels
that burn hot, and we have fuels that burn
long. I try to keep that as an anchor in my head,
that both of those things are vital.
Are there things that look practical,
you were talking about this a little bit earlier,
practical things that we are imagining paths
forward, actual policies that we need to be
working on. What does that look like?
[Maya:]
There is a campaign that literally just launched
two days ago. And whenever this comes up,
maybe it's longer than that.
[Hank:] Three days ago.
[Maya:] Yes, yes! It literally just launched.
Campaign Zero launched this initiative that
they're calling 8 Can't Wait.
And I'm obsessed
with it because it is, I feel like exactly
what was needed at this moment. People want
to see solutions, they want to be able to
advocate. And we also recognize, unfortunately
that we just don't have the leadership at
the federal level for this to get taken seriously.
And so, understanding all of that, what they
did is put together a list of eight demands
that we can call our local leaders,
call your mayors, these are things that can happen at
the local level. They do not require congressional action.
These are actions, because
I think the interesting thing, and one of
the tough things about regulating policing
in this country is that it is patchwork,
it's so based on cities. The other side though, of that,
is that we can engage in this kind of advocacy
and people can call mayors, and
you can go to their website and actually see,
based on your city, which of these policies
your city already has in place,
which ones still need to happen,
who you can call.
What they've put together
I think is, for a lot of people,
exactly what we were hoping for,
exactly what we were looking for.
It's something tangible that people can be working
toward, and it's something that really will
make a difference. I've seen in the last couple
of days, Vice President Biden, talking about
this stuff a lot more, like these are the things
that will make a difference. Banning chokeholds,
requiring just a universal national use of
force so that it's not whatever police officer
wants to do in a particular moment. There's
got to be more accountability for how people
respond in a moment.
And that's what this stuff is about.
I mean, honestly,
more than anything,
this is the kind of issue that will change because
there's political will. And so, finally talking
about this like it is a critical central issue.
I think so many times when we talk about things
like police violence or anything that touches
on racial justice, we treat it like...
it sort of gets cordoned off
and treated like it's an issue for one community.
And when something like this happens,
and we realize that that could not be further
from the truth. And so, people finally just
coming together and demanding action on this,
I think is hugely, hugely important,
and us actually being able
to do something about it.
[Hank:]
So, you've worked in the side of government a lot,
and you've seen politics functioning,
you've seen government functioning,
there are things that are broken about this, but
of course, I think the response to that can't be like,
"Okay, well, let's abandon it then.
Let's continue to hobble it. Let's ignore it."
It has to be, "Fix it.".
So how do we fix it?
[Silence]
[Hank laughs]
[Maya:] Well...
[Maya:]
I think a piece of it is, it's people.
It's people getting involved for the right reasons.
The people right now who are having this be one
of their formative political experiences,
they are going to be qualitatively different
types of leaders, because seeing something
like this and having that be the thing that sparks,
"I want to make change." So, I think
that, folks, that if you're called to want
to do something better
in a moment of crisis,
go run, do something,
get involved.
Because if that's the thing that sparks your interest
in making things better, you are one of the
people we want making things better. I think
beyond that, there are things about our politics
that are broken because...
because there is -
I mean, to put simply,
there's a cost to entry, right?
I mean, any time
there is a system where
if you have resources, your problems get greater
attention. And if you don't have those resources,
your problems get deprioritized. We are not
at a system that is best equipped to deal
with the issues that impact the most of us,
because most of us do not have those kinds
of resources. We have to fix what is, I think,
a baseline issue. And that is that our politics
are way too consumed by, who can get money
into the system and therefore have their issues
looked at first. And there's obviously campaign
finance reform solutions everywhere,
but I think acknowledging that is a big part of
what we need to do.
I also think we have to
step away from this idea that,
what I was saying before that when
we talk about issues like racial justice,
that we are talking about issues that only
are relevant to communities of color,
and as a result, they can be pushed off to the
side. I think that one of the tough things
about a moment like this is that we're talking
about policing, but we're also talking about
a system of white supremacy, and we're talking
about just a very fundamental difference in
the ways that people interact in the society,
and how they feel protected by the society,
and is based on race. And we have conditioned
ourselves to think of that as such a divisive topic
that we don't even want to talk about it
until we're confronted with something like this.
And then we're almost surprised that we are not
super good at talking about it with each other.
[Hank and Maya laugh]
Like we give ourselves no practice,
and then biggest things happen and
people are awkward around it, or people say
the wrong thing, or people you know -
And look, there are just some people that -
Obviously, there are some people
who do not care and are not worried that they
don't know what to say in this moment,
but I'm not really thinking about them. I'm more
thinking about the folks... genuinely are...
see a moment like this, feel the helpessness,
white folks who maybe haven't been as conscious
of some of this stuff and are having their
eyes open, but they don't know where to go,
and they don't know where to start, and they
don't want to say the wrong thing,
so they don't say anything.
And it's read differently.
So I think we've created
this really weird quagmire
around the way that we approach and
talk about race, that we only talk about it
in moments of crisis when the temperatures
are already so high. And the only people that
feel 100% comfortable talking about it are
people that study it and write about it and
talk about it, and people who don't care how
they sound talking about it. And so basically,
it is people who are racist or don't care
about sounding racist, talking to people who
make this their career to talk about. And
that's our national conversation around things.
And so, I think some of it
is almost just letting ourselves -
challenging ourselves to have the awkward
conversations. I think it goes back to this
question of grace. I think if people can come
in good faith and get grace in return,
I think that some of these conversations can get a
lot more comfortable and a lot more calm.
I mean, it doesn't mean they're not going
to be awkward, because they are, and they're
going to be tough, and they're going to be
courageous conversations you have to have
with people. But I do think that we have to
approach it as it's a necessity, we can't
wait until it's this
to engage in it at all.
And I'm realizing more and more
how much that still happens.
[Hank:] Because it is such an
important and big thing in our society,
I think it is important to
be curious about it, engage with it.
Because I think that you can't help if you're not
at all informed, and you also can't be like,
"Okay, the first step of me helping is to
place the burden on someone else to help inform me."
[Maya:] Right?
[Hank:] But like, you know...
You can't interface with anything
if you don't know about it. And so I think
that that learning process is really important.
It should be a bigger part of our education system,
but it should also be a part of what
we do as citizens.
It should be just something
that we feel is part of...
not even necessarily just an obligation,
but something that we should be passionate about.
[Maya:]
What you just described is, I think,
one of the tensions
that lies at the core of this.
[Hank:] Yeah, one of them.
[Maya:] There are people who want to learn and
their immediate thought is, "Oh, well, I'll ask someone."
Because, we do that with a lot of things in life.
"So I'll ask someone who seems
to know about this," and then immediately
that puts a burden on someone else. Sometimes
that is a burden that people are willing to
take on, and sometimes it's not. There's no
magic ingredient as to when that happens.
And so, I think a safe way to do it is,
people always say, "Well, Google and read."
And I think that that's great advice,
and I understand why that's people's advice.
But I also appreciate that
it's not like this stuff is
super accessible if you genuinely
are like, "I need to start from ground zero."
I think there are books out there that try
really, really hard to do that. There's a book called,
So You Want to Talk About Race,
that I think is incredible and does a really good job,
I think, from a, "Let's meet people
where they are standpoint." But I don't think
every book or article about racial justice
starts from a standpoint of [inaudible]
regardless of your level. There's a disconnect
there that I think we have to acknowledge
that sometimes we are saying, "We want people
to learn." And that means that there are people
who are curious and don't quite know where
to go with that.
And so, again,
I think it varies, but I also
think that a big way to the handle that is
having diverse friend groups. Because if you
hang with people and already have emotional
ties and a trust level, and they know that
your intentions are good, and you ask them
questions, people are going to be more willing
to take on that burden, they're going to be
more willing to give that grace, they're going
to be more understanding of, you didn't get
the vocabulary quite right, but I knew where
you were going. But I think that it's a chicken
and the egg thing because it is way too easy
for [inaudible] to be segregated,
especially for white folks. And then for people
to look around and say, "Oh wait, I don't
have anyone I'm close to I can ask about this.
Let me ask this random person."
And that's when -
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Maya:] And that's when there's -
So, I mean, it's tough, but it feels like the answer really
does seem to be community,  it's closer connection,
because we can do that stuff when we're already in
community with each other.
[Hank:]
One thing that we do every year here is
we have a census that we run
and I usually analyze it.
[Maya:]
I've taken that census before, yes.
[Hank:]
Okay, thank you. And I usually analyze it before now,
but haven't, because things got busy this year.
We ask a question about race
in that census, I think, that you were probably
aware, coming into this conversation that
the majority of the audience would be white folks.
So thinking about that, and introducing
this topic, maybe to people who have been really
apprehensive about it, or genuinely are coming
at it from a good place, but feel very anxious,
because it's a completely understandable thing
to be anxious about. One thing that I see
is two bad reactions to the concept of privilege.
One is, "I definitely don't have privilege, I have all
these hard things in my life, and so that's fake."
And the second is, "I have privilege,
I feel guilty about it, and I will
then move through my life with guilt," but
no positive anything on the other side of that?
And so it's like,
"Oh, so I've been given this negative emotion,
and I will just carry it around
and then do all my normal things."
I am very resistant to the idea that what you have
is something to feel ashamed of,
because I just think that we're all
in the situation that we're in.
But I heard Baratunde Thurston say,
this week in a podcast that,
"It's not like where everybody goes around
and says to Superman, "Stop using your power."
They say, "Use your power for good stuff."
And so, that really resonates with me
that this is about what you have, and what you have isn't
about how you should feel about what you have,
it's about what you should do with what you have.
[Maya:] Right.
So with that in mind,
what should we do with what we have?
[Maya:]
I love that framing. And I think you're right.
I mean, there is a knee jerk when you recognize
you have a privilege.
[Hank:] Sure.
[Maya:] It's sense of - right, it's like
you feel bad, you feel like, "Well then, but..."
And I think it's really important to work through that
because you're right, I think that the other side
of that is if I feel guilty about something,
I want to hide it,
I don't want to -
[Hank:] Or be angry or lash out -
[Maya:] Correct.
[Hank:] Shame is a terrible emotion
that no one wants to feel. Yeah.
[Maya:] Absolutely. And so,
working through it and acknowledging it
and saying it out loud, and I
think that that's important in and of itself.
Because I think you're right. Just having
that shame, it's so disruptive, but then... right?
There are so many things that come from that. The
recognition of white privilege in these conversations
means that there are conversations that would
be easier for you to have than for me to have.
No matter how many times I talk about race
a lot, I write about race a lot, I tend to
be a pretty effusive, friendly person. I try really hard
to say, "I'm still me when I'm talking about race."
But inevitably, as soon as I start talking
about race, there's more defensiveness
that I feel than if I were just talking about something fun
or something that people just want to talk to me -
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Hank:] Yeah!
[Maya:] But it happens, no matter and there's -
And I feel like I've gotten to a point where
there's no amount of, "I want to be super accessible
about it that is going to completely relieve that,"
because as soon as it's coming from me,
there is an assumption of,
"Okay, I've got to say the right thing, and I don't know
as much, so I can't say anything," and everything else
that comes along with that. Because of that, I pay a
bigger penalty for bringing that kind of stuff up.
One of the things that white privilege is
incredibly useful at doing is
helping to talk about some of the issues
that people of color can't bring up.
And so, being the one to talk about this,
taking a platform that you have,
and elevating work that's being done and voices
and stories that wouldn't otherwise get that platform,
acknowledging that there are ways
that privilege contributed to an ability to
build a platform, and therefore will bring the
next folks up. That kind of stuff is so valuable,
and it's so important, and it's only going to
come if people feel comfortable saying,
"Yes, I have privilege that has helped me. I am going
to make sure that I use that and help other people."
I mean, I think there's a lot tied up with it,
but this idea that
if you acknowledge privilege, it means you're somehow
undermining yourself, you haven't worked hard -
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Maya:] But it's like it's either or, that it's like
you did it 1000% by yourself, or
privilege is the only reason you are here versus here.
[Hank:] Yeah.
[Maya:] And getting to....
Please, you look like
you had on thought on that.
[Hank:]
My thought was that you're saying,
if you're recognizing your privilege that you're
somehow hurting yourself, you're saying like,
"Okay, I have privilege, and so I'm going to start
succeeding less," or something.
[Maya:] Right.
[Hank:] And I see people who think that.
But to me, it's like
helping people is the best part
of being successful.
It's like, being able to meet people who are amazing
and be like, people should pay attention to
this great person. And it's also well known,
psychologically, that helping other people
makes you happier than helping yourself. And
so, it's like, "But why wouldn't we do it?"
Of course, our brains don't think that, but
that's how we react.
There's this fairly famous study that
if you give somebody 50 bucks
and you say, "Spend it on yourself,"
or you say, "Spend it on someone else,"
that at the end of the day,
they would all prefer to spend it on themselves.
But at the end of the day, they're happier
when they spend it on someone else.
[Maya:] Right.
[Hank:] And so like,
being mindful and aware of that, and also
having had that experience a number of times,
I know it is true, even if it doesn't feel
intuitive all the time. So, to me, it's like,
"Oh, this is so wonderful that I have an opportunity
to use a power that I have."
[Maya:] Right.
[Hank:] Because that's really what privilege is,
is it's power.
Should be thinking more about how to use that,
because it makes me happier
and it makes the world better.
And those are
the two things I want.
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Maya:]
[inaudible] It's just that easy and clear. I mean, come on.
[inaudible]
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Maya:] It's true. And I also think
it's important to acknowledge that people
who don't have privilege, in some ways, have
privilege in other places, right?
[Hank:] Yeah.
[Maya:] I have an awful lot of privilege as a straight,
cis person, right? And we have the sense of you're either
privileged or you're not, it's binary, right?
And so, in different settings, I'm the one who
can say, "Wait a minute, there's something
I can bring up here that my queer friends couldn't,"
or "I can be the one to call out ableism,
because as an able bodied person, it's easier for me."
Right? So, I think that acknowledging
that around race conversations, yes, I'm going
to rely a lot more on my white friends who
want to act in allyship and bring this stuff
up when I can't. But there are going to be
rooms where I absolutely have
that ability to do it.
And so, I also think
that helps us sometimes,
because, again, if we conceptualize it as
you have it, or you don't, that makes it way
too easy to buy into this model of somehow
it makes me less than, or...
That it really is situational, and I think it's important that
we talk about it that way.
[Hank:] My last question here for you is,
what's making you hopeful right now?
[Maya:]
I will say again, watching the young people
who are leading this fight is incredibly,
incredibly inspiring.
It makes me feel like there are people who are seeing
this and are having that spark awakened in them.
And so, this becomes the issue that our movement is
taking up, that leaders are taking up.
I think that that is going to be huge. I am seeing
more of these conversations.
I've gotten a lot of people who've reached out to me
in these moments, who, these are friends that
I have strong relationships with, who have texted and
done the, "I want to check in. How are you feeling?"
But have gone further than that have said,
"I'm raising kids and I don't know
how I should be talking about this, but I know
that I haven't talked to my white kids about this.
And I know that peers who have Black kids
are already having to have these conversations.
So, "What do you think, what should I
be doing? What should I be saying?"
And I'm so grateful that it's like,
"Okay, people want to do this."
I think that there's so much power in
just being willing to say,
"Huh, I haven't thought about that before." Again, there's
vulnerability there, because there's the obvious part of,
"Well, how lucky am I that I never had to think about it."
And you could get stuck in that.
But instead, people are actually reaching out
and trying to do something different.
I'm seeing a lot more of the Facebook posts
where people... And my absolute, absolute
favorite thing is for people when they say,
"Hey, listen, if you're having this moment
right now, and you're hearing people say Black
lives matter, and you think to yourself,
'Well, all lives matter,' DM me."
One of the, I think hardest things -
[Hank:]
Wow, wow. Yeah, yeah, that's great.
[Maya:]
And it's so critical, because here's the thing.
You get on social media, and you're like,
"If you're thinking this, unfollow me,
if you're thinking this, I'm going to say..."
You're going to get a lot more likes and engagement.
And there's something really satisfying about
just unfollowing the family member who always
says the wrong thing or who... You get satisfaction
from that, and you get external validation from it.
But the actual helpful conversation
is one that you can only have in DMs.
Because it's the conversation where you say, "You
know what? Actually, I used to think this,"
or "I've actually had moments like this,"
and you make yourself vulnerable so this person
makes themselves vulnerable back. And you
can actually get to somebody in a way you
couldn't if [inaudible]
[Hank:] Yeah, yeah. Of course.
[Maya:] Nobody's changing their mind based on
an argument on someone's timeline on Facebook -
[Hank:]
Right. Publicly, performatively,
so that everybody's looking at it
and you can't show any weakness. Yeah.
[Maya:]
Exactly. It undermines every single thing
that would be valuable about this conversation.
You can't admit,
"Huh, I hadn't considered that." You can't do that.
But you can over DM, you can over phone calls.
And so that I think is so much of what we say when
there's a sense of like, "Go get your people."
The goal there is not, "Go excoriate on social media
your people." The idea is you...
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Maya:] And I think - look, again, I get it, even from a
standpoint that has nothing to do with
external validation, it feels good to have somebody say
something awful and you to slam the door in their face.
There's something satisfying about that,
but it's not helpful.
And I think that's one of the tough things
to remember about being an ally,
is that on some level it sucks.
It's not supposed to be easy,
it's doing a lot of the hard work. It feels good
because you know, you're doing the right thing,
not because in a moment it's satisfying.
You're actually supposed to do the stuff
that makes you a little uncomfortable,
and that gives an inch and lets that person
come in enough, and then say,
"Look, I get it. And here's how I got here."
Because that's the conversation that stays with them.
And so I've been really, really excited every time
I see that kind of stuff. Because I know that
the real work has to happen behind the closed doors,
and it doesn't get the likes, and it
doesn't get the retweets,
but it actually might be the thing that stops someone
from saying it the next time,
or that has someone think twice
the next time they're in a situation.
[Hank:]
Well, this has been a really wonderful conversation.
I appreciate you doing it. Also, thanks for
chatting with me offline a bit this morning.
So it was great to talk with you.
What was your first Vlogbrothers video?
[Maya:]
I saw the Harry Potter song.
[Hank:] Deathly Hallows? Wow!
[Maya:] Deathly Hallows.
[Hank:] Wow!
[Maya:] Yes!
So you've just been a nerd the whole time. I see what's -
[Maya:] I really have been!
So it was so funny, too,
because I remember I saw it because it was
featured on YouTube's homepage. I was not
a YouTuber, I did not know about this whole community.
I saw this, I was like -
[Hank:] Well, it was 2007.
No one did.
[Maya:] Thank you.
Thank you for that.
Because we're going to now pretend like
I definitely know so much
about YouTube.
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Hank:]
Now you're really in.
[Maya:] I know I'm deep in it.
[laughs]
I remember, and it was there
and I sent it to my sister.
And then I just saw that you guys
were doing this thing.
And I have a sister I'm very close to. And
so, I'm always really excited when siblings
are doing stuff together. I remember just
going back and I was so, and have remained...
And this is very genuinely true, I have remained
so impressed by this community that has been built,
because so much of, I think, what we were just
talking about is people seeking out community
and trying to have some grace and trying to
have some humility, is not always...
That doesn't always have a
very natural home online.
And I really thought here,
I don't myself make videos or anything,
but I remember there was a period of time where
people would make their own videos and share them.
And I felt this very -
Y'all had cultivated and brought together
a group of people who genuinely seem
to want to just do good things together. And
I've loved that. I loved the idea of the projects,
and there's a charity now!
Because P - you know what I mean?
[Hank and Maya laugh]
I've just been so consistently warmed by that,
and have always just been a big fan.
So I'm so grateful that you reached out, and
I'm so happy to have had this conversation.
[Hank:]
Oh, thank you so much! And I'm so grateful
that you're doing all of the work you're doing.
I'm grateful you're a part of this community,
but also other communities, and all this stuff
you're doing to help make the world
a bit of a better place.
Where can people find you?
[Maya:] I'm on Twitter.
[Hank:] Oh no!
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Maya:] I'm @MayaRupert on Twitter.
I think I'm the same on Facebook.
[Hank:]
So you're not on TikTok yet?
[Maya:]
I had interns teach me TikTok. I did one.
I wish we had saved the outtakes. Because
it was me just consistently not understanding
the vehicle at all.
[laughs]
[Hank:] Oh my God.
[Maya:] Yeah, this is - I feel like -
My social media is limited,
but I often am on Twitter.
[Hank:]:
Well, thank you so much, Maya.
[Maya:]
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
[Hank and Maya laugh]
[Maya:] That was awesome.
[Hank:] If you want to check out
So You Want to Talk About Race,
the book she was talking about,
that's linked to the description.
Also, 8cantwait.org.
The number 8can'twait.org.
It's a fantastic resource, makes it easy
to understand how to start
or continue work in advocacy,
trying to get some things changed.